617 830 for 750 let's take our next
caller going from Massachusetts to maybe
New York City our next caller from the
646 area code what's your name and where
you calling from today on my name's
Petey from South Carolina would have me
your phone number okay great what's on
your mind but that's the derivative I
have a quick question yeah I don't know
if you covered it broke anybody's access
question but how come when you do not
agree with something um and just by the
democratic or republican that you just
say I do not agree when you support the
party but you do not agree with
something within the party cause all I
want to know so let me see if I
understand what you're saying is that
sometimes when a Republican for example
is confronted with some crazy thing that
a Republican said you're saying that
Republicans sometimes for whatever
reason won't just say hey listen I'm a
Republican I mostly agree with
Republicans but I don't agree with that
that one thing doesn't change that I'm a
Republican is that is that what you're
asking why aren't people willing to do
that more exactly yeah exactly I mean I
think it's because most of the time that
you're presented with something like
that you're being presented with it by
someone with an opposing view who's
probably trying to score a political
point so if you're if someone confronts
you and said you're voting for Trump
Trump said ban all Muslims if you say
well listen i don't agree with that but
i'm still a Republican you probably feel
like you're opening yourself up to the
person saying and you're willing to vote
for the guy who says something so crazy
that you don't agree what do you think
Pat my sense is it feels like you're
admitting sort of a weaker position in
political debate if you say something
like that yeah that's spot-on because
while it's perfectly consistent to say I
still does I still agree with this
person ninety percent of the time I
don't necessarily agree with this action
or this statement that they made but I
think you assess it correctly they don't
want to put themselves in a vulnerable
position politically yeah that's my
sense of it all right there that's it
the follow one to know all right thanks
so much really appreciate the call